à morpa lundi après-midi pourtant à
l'entraînement à Marseille quelques
heures auparavant Benjamin stulis
n'aurait pas manqué ce rendez-vous avec
la relève de la natation
éinoise j'ai pas envie de dire que les
jeunes enfin je suis l'idole des jeunes
mais voilà moi a une dizaine d'années
c'était pareil pour moi j'avais de
grands nageurs qui venaient au bord du
bassin et j'avais les yeux qui brillent
voilà si c'est à mon tour je peux rendre
les enfants heureux ça me fait très
plaisir lors de cette 11e édition sous
la pluie 280 nageurs se sont affrontés
de quoi avoir quelques embouteillages
dans les lignes d'eau l'organisation a
dû même supprimer du programme le 200 m
quatenag pour faire tenir toutes les
épreuves sur une seule journée le
meeting ctinois n'avait pas de réel
enjeu sportif cette compétition permet
aux nageurs de se tester physiquement
dans leur préparation en grand bassin
c'est un meeting de niveau régional qui
permet aux nageurs bah de voir un peu
leur niveau pour pour attaquer
les comment dire les objectifs finaux
donc entre autes pour certains il y a
les championnats de France au mois de
juin au mois de juillet de son côté
Benjamin stul se prépare au jeux
méditerranéen fin juin en Turquie espère
décrocher un premier podium en